you'd think if you're going to tell
children to put on masks because there
would be some kind of evidence evidence
isn't there a whole time and then
secondly it's the kind of nervous system
that you see this is a political nervous
system we're overly worried that
so-and-so is doing the Nicholas
surgeon's doing this maybe we better
catch up with her and then Chris Woody
has said look Chris is there any
scientific evidence to this you'll say
well maybe maybe not it doesn't really
matter it's not worth the fight but
Chris what he's saying it's not worth a
fight isn't a scientific judgment it's a
political judgment coming from a
scientist so we now see when we were all
told that we're following the science
just the form that took so you get to
see not so much in the big stories but
more of a smaller day-to-day
conversations the rule these scientists
had they were basically their mutes
quite a lot of the time they were you
know saying stuff they were but they
were be allowing themselves to be used
so this was very much a political
response to the pandemic with science
being invoked as political cover and
scientists as well being invoked for
political coverage